bonjour je m'appelle alec gb 9 ans
j'habite à saint denis et chasse un
poste dans la vente j'ai eu mon bac
économie sociale en 2003 à saint génis
j'ai ensuite passé une licence en
première année de licence à lyon 2 et
j'ai aussi mon cas c'est 3,5 pour la
logistique tout au long du parcours
professionnel j'ai eu plusieurs
expériences dans la vente
que ce soit ici à la réunion ou en
métropole en métropole j'ai travaillé de
l'avant en taclant four dans les ventes
aux enchères et à la rhino ce travail
agile et à la grande récré j'ai aussi
plus d'expérience dans la logistique
coup j'étais cariste et chef du quai
d'orsay
les grandes multinationales qui est
geodis traumatique j'ai aussi travaillé
dans le domaine
ferroviaire j'ai déchargé charger les
trains je connais donc les règles de
sécurité dans un grand dépôt et aussi
dans un gène car je suis aussi un grand
passionné de sport que j'ai pratiqué
d'ailleurs suit son ancien club de foot
j'ai fait beaucoup de marche et de
course à pied je suis très souriant et
dynamique je sais m'adapter à toutes les
situations
je suis très autonome et je sais
travailler seul ou en équipe maintenant
vous me connaissez un peu mieux j'espère
vous ne protesterait je suis disponible
dès demain et mobile